in this video we will begin to explore
the field of ethology which is the study
of animal behavior and amol behavior and
the word itself
ethology it has its roots in the Greek
ethos and you also might be familiar
with the word ethics ethos and ethics
you keep seeing this F and it's
generally referring to somethings
character so you could see this is the
study of the character of animals or in
general the behavior of animals and so
let's just first think of a framework
and then we're going to try to apply it
to different types of animal behaviors
that we see so first what is behavior
well you have some type of environmental
stimulus and it evokes some type of a
response some type of a response in the
animal and so that is a pretty good
definition of what behavior of what
behavior actually is it's some type of
response to stimulus in an environment
the stimulus could be another animal
doing something it could be the
temperature it could be the availability
of food it might be the the sun setting
who knows but it's some type of response
due to that stimulus now so that's the
first thing we're gonna look at the
second thing is well how did this
behavior come about that was it learned
was it innate so learned behavior that
animals saw something else do and said
hey that's a good idea next time I see
that stimulus or they might not even be
thinking that much about it but somehow
they are trained to do it whenever
whenever they did that behavior they got
rewarded somehow or whatever else and
the other option is it's an eight the
animal would have done it even if there
was no training even if they never had
observed it it's in there it's in their
genetics somehow and the third question
we're going to ask ourselves is well
what's the benefit here what's the
benefit here especially in a case or in
a context
of natural selection or you know how did
it evolve and it should have evolved
because there's some benefit where the
the members of a species that have that
behavior are selected for its a natural
selection so now that we have a little
bit of our framework let's let's think
about some animal behaviors well right
over here I have a baby crying and yes
we humans it's nice to remind ourselves
that we are animals we should feel very
proud to be part of this animal kingdom
and the behaviors of is is the child
crying and I'll assume that this child
is maybe hungry there's many reasons why
a baby might cry as you might discover
when you have one I have three now and I
think I have most of the reasons down
but let's say for in this context the
stimulus is a lack of food lack of food
and it responds it leads to the response
of crying my two-year-old just the other
day was screaming from his screaming
from his crib I want food and and and he
was kind of crying it out and and so
that that type of behavior where you
have lack of food leading to crying well
let's think about it let's actually
let's first think about what's the
benefit of that it's almost obvious or
it's almost too obvious well if a baby
didn't do that then the parents might
might not notice that it's hungry and
the baby might not get the food might
get malnourished or an extreme case
might starve and so by crying it it
allows other people say oh I need to
feed that baby because the baby isn't
able to go hunt down its own food it
isn't able to you know get in the car
and go buy a sandwich or go to the
fridge and make itself some cereal it
needs other people to do it and even the
behavior that I might have as a parent
to say oh my god my son is crying I need
to go get him some food that that itself
is a behavior the stimulus so there's
one stimulus the child's hungry leading
to the response of the child crying and
then that response is then a stimulus to
me to say to have the responsible oh let
me feed my child so
they stop crying and so you can imagine
it has a significant benefit in natural
selection you could imagine and I think
it would be you wouldn't this this
probably happened in our evolutionary
history far before humans came about but
whatever organism you're talking about
or some animal
if the offspring that are better at
making it known that they are hungry
especially if these offspring are
dependent on saw on their parents or
something else to get them food well the
ones that that cry are more likely to
get the food and are more likely to
survive and pass their DNA on to future
generations and so it makes sense this
is this is almost an obvious one why
this is favorable from a natural
selection point of view another
interesting question and this is you
should even ask this about your own
behavior anything that you observe is is
that behavior learned versus innate I
haven't run any experiments here but I
would I would guess my hypothesis is
that the baby crying in response to not
having food that this is innate that a
baby no one has to teach a baby to do
this it's somehow programmed into their
DNA it's programmed into their brain
they don't have to be trained to cry now
one my five-year-old cries because I
didn't give her dessert even though she
has just eaten a full meal I think that
might be learned she might be seeing
that hey her younger brother tends to
get his way when he cries maybe at five
years old I should still do that even
though I really don't have to because
because I really don't need that dessert
that might be learned so once again it
depends on the context and it's a really
interesting thing to think about but
let's move on to other members of the
animal world
this right here is pipi who works at
Khan Academy so pipi and when there is
food around Pippi acts extra cute and
needy so let's so the stimulus here is
food I guess there's a food theme here
maybe I need to be eating some food
so maybe when I have a maybe when I have
a lack of food my response is making a
video about it but anyway wait when
Pippy is around food acts extra extra
cute and needy and I think all of us
have seen dogs behave this way and it
might just seem like a simple thing but
this this is actually could be a very
important behavior for a dog that you
know we know what the stimulus what the
response is learn versus an eight well
it might be a little bit of both and
that's something you'll see as you try
to analyze more and more of animal
behaviors is that well it's it's
sometimes a knut continuum maybe there's
an inclination to to do that behavior
but by learning it they get better at it
so maybe Pippy would have always been
somewhat needy around food but when it
sees other dogs do it then more likely
to to learn that behavior and a good
example of something that's in between
learned and an eighth for human beings
is language and we can do a whole series
people dedicate their their lives to
studying human language but we think we
have a lot of reason to believe that
humans have an innate bias to wanting to
communicate and having these this
structured language but you clearly
learn your particular language probably
if human beings were to just if you
throw a bunch of babies on an island
which sounds like a very is a very cruel
experiment at some point they they if
they survive they they would develop
their own language but we also know that
if you put a baby in the context of
someone speaking English or a French or
Hindi or whatever else that they will
actually learn the language so these two
things are not always one way or the
other in fact in most cases it's
someplace in between or it's a
combination of learned and an eighth but
let's go back to Pippi why is that a
what's the benefit there well it's a way
of getting food why would that be
selected for well the the wolves
thousands of years ago that were better
at it kind of getting close to humans
and acting extra cute and and needy well
though they were able to get food they
didn't have to hunt it down themselves
and that's actually how dogs came about
and we could think of many many other
examples so this right over here
this is a possum playing dead kind of a
famous behavior so when there is a
threat when there's a threat maybe a
predator around this opossum plays dead
plays dead I would guess it's
interesting to think about whether it's
an eight or learned that this is an
eight then they didn't have to see
another possum do this behavior in fact
it might and might they might not even
be able to help it when their stress
hormones go up high enough they might
just turn into this a looking dead State
and a lot of times just to you know when
people's hey that's instinct they're
often talking about an innate behavior
in distinct it's not saying oh well
maybe if I play dead and act really well
that predator might not come it just
can't help it maybe you know it's
hormones go up and it just gets into the
state and you might say well what's the
benefit there it seems like it's easy to
catch well other animals might not like
eating things that are dead maybe at
things that has a disease or whatever
else and it doesn't want to catch it and
so something about the evolutionary past
of possums or pre possums they were
selected for the ones that were able to
do this had a higher chance of not being
killed and then passing on their
offspring and so we now see this in
possums and once again we could go
through a whole range of behaviors from
hibernation there's also a phenomenon
actually that so there's things like
hibernation where bears favorite Slee
hibernate for the winter why is that
useful
well the stimulus is it's getting colder
in a different part of the season and so
they'll hibernate why is it useful well
it they lower their metabolic rate their
need for food when there's less
availability of food and so that also
can can give you clues about why it
might have been selected for there's
actually a a similar or a form of
hibernation I guess you could say called
estivation estivation which I actually
didn't know this word until I started
looking into this and this is and
sometimes in in the u.s. they don't put
the a in front it's just estivation with
the e but this is a a form of of going
into a lower metabolic state when things
are really hot so this is or very dry
when you don't have availability of
water so it's it's it's it's less
familiar than hibernate
for the winter but it's another form of
getting into a lower metabolic state you
might say well why does that happen why
would that be selected for which animals
do that and is it innate is it learned I
would I would propose that both of these
are an eight that the animal most of the
animals that do this would do it
regardless of whether they somehow got
trained or observed some other animal
doing it